question from michael dear swarthy
podcast host my wife and i differ
politically
i am a staunch conservative she is a
more classical
liberal with some leftist positions for
example
she likes the idea of critical race
theory but hates the idea of big
government
okay we typically have good civil
debates
the main issue that we disagree on is
abortion i have pointed out
that the low rates of rape and incest
related abortions
but she counters with the idea that a
lot of these go unreported due to fear
of backlash
she has also pointed out that members of
the military accidentally killing
civilians in other countries go
typically unpunished
okay seems like a non-sequitur but okay
ultimately she says
that as a man it is not my place to tell
a woman
what to do with her body but i say that
it is not just a woman's body at stake
what are your thoughts on this most
specifically about the two argument
arguments i mentioned your wife is just
dead wrong i'm sorry to say and uh it's
your
your responsibility as the head of the
household to show her that
first of all if she considers herself a
classical liberal
she really can't defend abortion the
reason for this and you know i'm not a
classical liberal i'm a conservative but
if you're a classical liberal especially
in the american tradition
then politics to you boils down to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
right
or life liberty and the protection of
property
well you can't pursue happiness or
have your property if you don't have
liberty
and you can't have liberty if you don't
have life the right to life
according to classical liberalism is not
just one
right among many it's not you know i
have a right to uh
go to the doctor or something if you
think about positive rights the way
people are talking about it today
uh and then i also have a right to life
no the right to life comes first and if
you're talking about the negative rights
of classical liberalism you can't have a
right to liberty without the right to
life so
the the abortion i think she should
change your position on abortion even
even from that as a matter of critical
race theory it's just
uh it's just poison to a body politic i
mean there's no
because because you know i don't want to
oversimplify it too much but critical
theory generally
is uh the theory to criticize it it goes
back to marx's
famous description uh of his plan uh
for the ruthless criticism of all that
exists
um it's more involved in that it goes
even cookier than that but that's what
it boils down to
and so if you are keen on these kind of
modern ideologies what they all amount
to
is you've got to hate your country your
civilization
the way society is set up you've
yourself
you know you you've you've got your
religion
you've just got to hate these things um
because they're
because what you're engaging in is a
radical criticism of them
uh so that's unfortunate in terms i
don't really know what she's talking
about with the uh
killings killing civilians i suppose
that
often is punished even if it does go on
punished doesn't really matter uh and
and the rape and incest issue i mean
that's
it is simply the case that uh it's less
than one percent
of abortions and by the way before roe
versus wade we were told that thousands
of women died every year from abortions
that isn't true
that the real number was double digits
and it was statistically
uh the same when you when you consider
how many states had legal abortion and
illegal abortion
the number of women who died from
illegal abortions was statistically
almost identical to the number of women
who died from legal abortion so all
those scientific arguments are bunk but
really you should get around the
philosophical argument
that it's just uh it's indefensible to
call yourself a defender of liberty and
not defend life
you